this video sponsored by Squarespace the
best way to make an amazing website hey
guys it's max with Mac's tech today
we're gonna be doing an ultimate
comparison p-ting our top of the line 16
inch macbook pro as far as performance
against razors new 15-inch studio laptop
that is designed for professional work
and is just set up to compete and maybe
beat out the MacBook Pro so I love
razor's design the box
magnetic little flap they're doing a
great job there and let's pull out this
tab right away I can feel that this
thing definitely has a bit more
chunkiness and weight not that it's big
or heavy 4.8 pounds compared to 4.3 but
just feeling this thing in my hand it
feels really really nice all aluminum
and one thing I love is that the logo on
the studio Edition is not green it's not
gamer II it's very subtle let's open
this thing up here and get rid of this
the first thing that stands out is the
spork' touch display yes this is an OLED
and in this video we're going to compare
these screens the keyboards the speakers
the CPU performance and especially the
graphics performance both on battery
power and when you're up you know
plugged in that's because this thing has
a Quadro r-tx 5000 graphics card with 16
gigabytes of memory that is absolutely
massive and I think that's one of the
big selling points for professionals
with this laptop and we'll see what kind
of difference that makes in the real
world compared to the AMD graphics
that's inside of the macbook pro let's
jump right into comparing the different
ports and options I'll start with the 16
inch macbook pro because it's very
simple we have two Thunderbolt three
ports on this side another two
Thunderbolt three ports on this side and
our headphone jack that is all
now with the Razer studio we have a ton
of ports we do have a proprietary
charging port we'll talk about charging
and batteries here in just a second we
have two USB type 8 ports and these are
full speed ten gigabit per second so
nice and fast on the connections we have
a headphone jack and flipping around to
the other side we have a Kensington lock
we have a DisplayPort output over here
an HDMI output another
USB type a port and then one single
thunderbolt three ports now the last
thing we have here is an SD card reader
not only does it have one where the
macro doesn't I wish it did this is a
UHS three card reader which can read at
just over 600 megabytes per second and
I'm so glad that Razer went with the
newest technology in fact there are no
SD cards out there that actually use
this yet but when they come out in a
year or two you're gonna get to be able
to get full speeds with this laptop now
if we compare the studio to this one
it's actually slightly smaller it's not
as tall slightly shorter by just a tiny
bit so the overall size that is heavier
but if we take a look at the thickness
it is definitely clear that the razor
studio is thicker taking a look at the
back we see that the full hinge is made
out of aluminum just like the MacBook
which is fantastic but we do have a
plastic insert which I'm guessing is
used for Bluetooth and Wi-Fi and this
studio razor has Wi-Fi 6 which will give
you better range and you know stronger
signal through walls and also faster
speeds compared to Wi-Fi of 5 on the
MacBook Pro now looking a bit lower we
have this large cutout for the exhaust
of the hot air and this thing has a lot
of powerful components packed in so they
are probably oriT izing the thermals
which I'm excited to test out here in
just a bit now on the bottom we have two
intakes for fans and because these are
on the bottom a razor who put these very
large standoffs that are quite thick to
make sure that air can get in and with
this design if you put this laptop on
say if you're laying in bed you have
your comforter there or blanket that's
going to be blocking this whereas I
really like what Apple does where if you
set this on your lap or anywhere the
intakes are actually on the sides that
are tapered off so you're not blocking
your airflow and of course the exhaust
comes out here out of the back now I'm
about to compare the track pads and the
keyboards but I have to mention the
power adapters and the battery so the
razor comes with this really
high-quality really nice a power adapter
we have these braided cables
this really crazy proprietary connector
that it's very large but it looks very
durable and this thing is 230 watts of
power that it can give to the laptop and
it definitely needs that whereas Apple
just upped their power adapters this is
now 96 Watts so 96 compared to 230 this
uses USB type-c and one thing I really
like about Apple's implementation is
that it doesn't need that much wattage
meaning if you have a car that has a
power outlet you're gonna be able to
charge this with it or on an airplane it
will accept whereas these guys that draw
so much power they little shut off on
you it won't give you anything now
another thing that I want to mention is
the internal battery life we have 80
watt hours which is great for a razor
compared to pretty much a hundred with
the macbook pro tech radar rated at 11
hours and 40 minutes versus 5 hours and
30 minutes for their mix test now that's
a huge difference
now the last thing that I mentioned
about power is the fact that you can
charge and run your macbook pro off of a
cheap USB power bank like this let's go
ahead and open these up and check out
the hinges nice both of these are
excellent the razor has a great hinge
easy to open with one hand the cutout
isn't as deep as a MacBook but its wider
it works just as well so a great job on
that racer and let's take a look over
here
the MacBook is known for having a
massive trackpad and the Reiser isn't as
big but for a Windows laptop this is
huge of course it's not a magnetic the
trackpad like apples which is excellent
so you do have a difference in feel noma
you know depending where you're clicking
of course with apples trackpad you can
configure how sensitive it is how much
of a click you feel because in reality
it's magnets you don't actually press
down at all and it definitely is a step
above pretty much everything else on the
market now let's go ahead and turn on
the razor here and we have a power
button that is kind of in the speaker
grille and it does not seem to be a
fingerprint scanner or a fingerprint
reader whereas the Mac does have touch
ID built into it now the razor does have
Windows hello built in which is awesome
I don't know as far as like how secure
it is but
is super convenient you open up the
laptop and it automatically sees your
face and signs you in now I'm a really
big fan of the new magic keyboard inside
the new 16 inch MacBook Pro the keys are
fairly large they have a good tactile
feedback when you're clicking them
almost like it's you know getting closer
to a mechanical keyboard and they're
very nice and stable Apple did a
fantastic job now I spent a little bit
of time here with the studios keyboard
and I just mistyped a couple times it
doesn't have as much travel which is
weird compared to the MacBook Pro it
also doesn't have that same kind of
feedback when you're clicking it and
they're not as stable and the keys are
slightly smaller as well so because of
that like instead of hitting V I just
hit B I'm sure you can get used to it
but the keyboard is definitely not as
good
comparing the keyboard backlighting both
of these look really good it's an
individual led perky so we don't have a
bunch of bleed outside of the keyboard
the razor studio does have RGB LEDs so
right now as you guys could see it is
shifting different colors over here it
is a little bit brighter but it is a
little bit more difficult to see because
we're lighting up these the letters on
top of white key caps so you don't have
that contrast that you do with the
MacBook Pro but that has black key caps
now right above the MacBooks keyboard I
have to mention the touch bar now this
thing is controversial yes there are a
few times where it is convenient me
personally but overall I wish Apple
didn't spend the extra money for that
oled touchscreen chip and the controller
that it needs to you know power all of
that and just go back to having a
regular keyboard now next we're gonna
compare the speakers between these two
we know the MacBook Pro has some really
great speakers I'm excited to hear these
ones but first let me give a shout-out
to our sponsor Squarespace if you've
been thinking about making your own
website Squarespace is seriously the
best way to go you can build an engaging
website for your business your blog
portfolio or for e-commerce with
literally no web making experience you
just choose a template customize blocks
of text and images and easily move them
around it's incredibly simple affordable
and our site has been running flawlessly
for almost two years bringing in new
clients thanks to its built
in SEO tools so whether you're making a
website for a small business or anything
else go to squarespace.com slash max tag
for a free trial and use our custom link
below when you're ready to launch to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain now let's pick these
laptop speakers against each other we
have our $500 rode ntg-3 R and make sure
you put on your best headphones that you
have but I'll still give you guys my
opinion after this let's start out with
the studio laptop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay guys you heard that for yourselves
my mind is blown I mean I knew the
MacBook Pro would do better it has you
know six speakers two of those are
dedicated woofers Apple really had a
focus on the audio quality and now let's
compare the quality of the built in 720p
webcams and the microphones you guys let
me know down in the comments section
below which one you think looks better
and sounds better this is a webcam and
microphone quality test with the Razer
Blade 15 studio Edition this is a webcam
and microphone test with a 16 inch
macbook pro and now let's compare the
displace and we have a lot of
differences both positives and negatives
with both the MacBook Pro has a standard
LCD it is a 3k display it has nice
contrast and nice colors the razor
studio this thing is an OLED display
meaning there is no backlight like the
LCD each pixel emits its own light and
that means that the blacks could be pure
deep black but that is not what I am
noticing on this 4k touchscreen when I
was doing this audio test I'm saying so
much reflections on the razor and then I
see way way less on the MacBook Pro and
because of that now the blacks here even
though they should be pure black they
look slightly grayish because of all of
that reflection whereas these are not
pure black but they do look a lot darker
and you guys could see that now not only
do we have the difference in reflection
but the LCD display on the MacBook Pro
is rated at 500 nits of brightness
compared to 350 with a full screen
that's lit up on the razor meaning if
you're outside you have a dimmer display
and it is more reflective which means
it's gonna make it a lot more difficult
to use now as I mentioned the razor is a
touch screen which can be convenient and
it is fairly responsive using it with
touch but do keep in mind with it being
so shiny and reflective those
fingerprints are very very easy to see I
mentioned that the MacBook is brighter
overall but if you're looking off axis
there's a lot more brightness
shift with the MacBook Pro then there is
with the razor but there is less color
shift so it's kind of a win and lose
with both of them
now the razor screen is 4k so when we're
playing back 4k video you definitely see
that it's a little bit more detailed a
little bit sharper because there's about
20% more pixels and along with that we
don't have any black bars that are added
of course we have this really big chin
on here because this is a 16 by 9
display with 16 by 9 by 9 video whereas
the MacBook screen is a 16 by 10 so we
have the extra height now this OLED
screen also supports HDR so in a video
like this some of the highlights are a
little bit brighter and some of the
shadows are darker now unfortunately
when the light is turned on right here
I'm seeing different reflections even
what they kind of maxed out at the
darker parts and that kind of ruins it
so if you want a great movie watching
experience you want to turn off the
lights or have a dimmer kind of room to
watching and that is where it's really
gonna look excellent with colors and
contrast especially is that OLED is
gonna come into play of course make sure
you have headphones or external speakers
not the built-in ones now one thing I
want to point out is that if you're
doing color critical work you want to
get a screen calibrator and calibrate to
one specific brightness and then
whenever you're editing photos or video
state at that brightness because OLED is
more sensitive to different color shifts
if you adjust it compared to LCD and now
finally let's get into performance I'm
gonna run the latest version of
Geekbench this is 5.1 we're gonna start
out with the CPU test and I'll jump into
specs while this is running so both
these have 32 gigabytes of RAM the
MacBook is soldered in with the razor
you can upgrade it yourself but if you
want to jump up to the 64 which is the
max on both these machines it will cost
you roughly 400 bucks cuz you have to
remove the two sticks that are installed
whereas Apple charges $400 to go up to
64 they both have a terabyte SSD but
I'll talk about that a little bit in
detail here in a bit and we have a
difference in the CPUs both are Intel 9
gen but we have a 6 core CPU for the
razor studio and an 8 core 2.4 gigahertz
on the MacBook Pro there is
are in and for single-core that
performance is very similar but in
multi-core we have 36% more performance
with the eight core I nine MacBook Pro
now let's do a little bit of a tougher
test this is cinnamon jar 20 and we'll
also take a look at the clock speeds and
we'll see what they're doing as far as
temps so our first set bench run with
the razor was very weird
our clock speeds were good at first and
the CPU wasn't really heating up and
then it dropped down to 2.6 gigahertz
which is the base and then it got even
lower to 2.5 gigahertz and the CPU only
reached 60 degrees Celsius with the fans
being quite cool and the the actual CPU
is only drawing 35 watts and our
Cinebench score is quite disappointing
as you guys could see even though we
were set to full performance mode so I
did some digging and you have to go into
Razer synapse a software which crashed
on me a couple times but here we are in
here and this overrides the windows
control this is very important if you
buy this machine and you don't want to
you don't think you want to deal with
your RGB LEDs and all that kind of stuff
you might just totally ignore it but
you're gonna be missing out on a lot of
performance if you're pushing the CPU to
the max so we're gonna go in here hit
custom and it's set to medium and we're
just gonna go high on the CPU and also
high on the graphics card and then save
it let's go ahead and run Cinebench one
more time and now BAM we just hit 50 is
70 Watts right there 79 watts out of the
two the CPU from the outlet that's
excellent our temps now 75 degrees
Celsius and we're running at 3.6 3.8
gigahertz 3.9 pretty solid alright the
results are in we have a score of 2439
on the racer and 3262
on our MacBook Pro and how they get
there is a huge difference of the way
these laptops are designed so that's
about 35 percent faster with the 16 inch
MacBook Pro which makes sense but this
guy right here
they actually spiked up to about 77
watts and that's just for a little tiny
second and then it drops down to 45
watts just like it's designed to the
base TDP of the chip and where's the
Apple one will go up to like 88 watts
and then I'll try
to stay at about 60 65 watts meaning is
pushing more electricity juice into the
CPU it's making it heat up higher but
it's running at the same 3 to 3.1
gigahertz on eight cores whereas this
runs at a solid 3 gigahertz with only
six now this once it's stabilized the
fans are quieter than the MacBook Pro
and the CPU is running a lot cooler 65
degrees Celsius compared to over 90 now
Apple could max out the fans or you
could do it yourselves but they're ok
with having to be that hot in trying to
keep the fans lower but ultimately of
course the mac pro has a lot more CPU
performance
now before we test at the graphics let
me quickly mention the SSDs both these
have a one terabyte SSD built in and
with the razor you are stuck with that
you have no other options
at least when you're ordering it from
the factory whereas with the MacBook Pro
you can go up to a 2 terabyte for $400
more you could go for a 4 terabyte and
even go up to an 8 terabytes internally
which is crazy but it is soldered in
here you have to upgrade it yourself and
if you want to go say get a a 2 terabyte
it's gonna cost about 500 bucks
and then the quality is still not as
good as the SSD that you get in the
MacBook Pro that does not slow down with
large capacities or depending on how
full it is so if you want the best SSDs
the Mac offers that and it's all built
in and with high capacities compared to
the razor and now finally the graphics
and we see a massive difference in
Geekbench 5's OpenCL tests where I can
compare them side-by-side we have almost
27,000 versus almost 97 thousand that's
a massive difference about three times
more performance with the r-tx Quadro
5000 that has double the video memory
and here of course it's a lower power
champ and doesn't need as much wattage
and the performance really shows as well
now I want to do one more test I'm gonna
unplug both these laptops because the
graphics card inside of the razor it
needs a lot of power to run so if you
start doing some work on the go even if
you max out all your performance
settings is gonna be limited and Wow
so the Mac Pro actually got slightly
faster somehow on battery
there actually is not a difference
between plugged in and plug there's no
performance modes everything is
automatic and it runs well whereas with
Windows you have those modes and here we
went from almost a hundred thousand to
now 33 thousand eight hundred and now
these are very close we have
twenty-seven thousand one hundred
seventy-five thirty-three thousand eight
hundred so yes it's still better even on
battery power but you can see the
massive amount of performance you lose
when you're you know unplugged and then
we set Windows to maximum performance
but in the Razer setting it actually
says that to use performance modes your
system must be plugged into a power
outlet and that is because this graphics
card needs a ton of power as you guys
saw with the the power adapter having
230 watts versus 96 with the Mac now if
you want to see some real-world testing
I'm going to be comparing both of these
side-by-side with a variety of different
video editing tests if you guys want to
see that there's gonna be a link down in
the video description where you guys go
check out our other channel that is more
for filmmaking and make sure you
subscribe if you want to see how they
actually compare but overall performance
wise the Mac definitely ones on the CPU
and the razor definitely wins on the
graphics if you do have that plugged in
and now the final topic and that is
price Apple not only made the 16 inch
MacBook Pro better in a lot of ways
faster they also drop the price and so
the razor now is $500 more expensive
than the MacBook Pro now if we get the
same processor that's in the razor
that's another three hundred dollars of
savings and then you can upgrade your
RAM get a better SSD stuff like that so
now the MacBook is looking a more
affordable the razor it has a nicer
screen as long as you're not going to be
in bright areas or outside us because of
the reflections and it's built really
well for a Windows computer the track
that is fairly nice but still the
keyboard isn't compared to the MacBook
the track track doesn't and definitely
the speaker's so the biggest selling
point is graphics if you're a gamer you
can look at their other models or this
one it's going to do great or if you're
doing 3d animations where it can make
use of the Quadro graphics card with
r-tx
that is going to be the real real big
selling point with this machine compared
to the AMD graphics inside of the
MacBook Pro and of course if you like
having a lot of ports you don't want to
deal with adapters dongles any of that
is very nice to have the convenience of
having all of that built in overall it's
a nice machine but if you're somebody
that edits on the go you're productive
you want the better battery life the
brighter screen that's less reflective
better keyboard the macro wins in that
area so we're gonna have links to both
of them down in the video description if
you guys want to go and check those out
let us know any questions you have in
the comments and click that little
circle above if you want to subscribe
and there's a couple great videos right
over there for you guys
this man Max and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]